[Musique]
madame monsieur bonsoir l'essentiel de
ce journal sera consacrée à l'accident
d'un concorde d'air france cet après
midi près de roissy un appareil
spécialement affrété par un groupe
d'allemands qui partait en croisière
l'avion a décollé vers 16h30 de roissy
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquète
l'un de ses moteurs étaient en feu et il
s'est écrasé près d'un hôtel à gonesse
il y aurait 113 morts les 100 passagers
tous allemands qui partait en vacances
et s'envoler vers new york
les neuf membres d'équipage et 4
personnes ou cinq personnes qui se
trouvaient au sol lionel jospin et jean
claude gayssot le ministre des
transports se sont immédiatement rendus
sur place jacques chirac exprime son
émotion
c'est la première fois qu'à concorde
s'écrase au sol depuis son premier vol
en 1969 et sa mise en service en 1967
je vous le disais donc l'essentiel de ce
journal sera consacré à cette
catastrophe avec nos envoyés spéciaux
sur place et puis nous irons aux états
unis en israël alors que bill clinton a
annoncé tout à l'heure l'échec du sommet
de cannes des vite mais d'abord donc cet
accident de ce concours d'air france
avec d'abord les circonstances de
l'accident par patrick forian on
entendait les restes du conflit je vous
entends
l'âme de la carlingue est au sol près de
400 pompiers mobilisés dans un épais
nuage de fumée
ce sont les premières images qui nous
sont parvenus de la zone de roissy où le
vol air france est écrasée il y un peu
plus de trois heures le supersonique est
tombé en partie sur un hôtel de gonesse
le bilan provisoire fait au théâtre de
113 morts 4 autour de l'hôtel neuf
membres de l'équipage et 100 passagers
tous allemands qui se rendait à new york
avant de partir pour une croisière
immédiatement le plan rouge a été
déclenché tous les secours
d'ile-de-france convergent vers la zone
de l'accident
les opérations de recherche des corps se
poursuivent sur place il y aurait encore
des blessés dans l'hôtel le premier
ministre s'est rendu sur place en
compagnie de jean claude dissaux
ministre des transports et de
l'équipement
les enquêteurs eux sont déjà à pied
d'oeuvre pour rassembler des indices
une enquête judiciaire vient d'être
ouverte pour tenter de trouver les
causes de l'accident
la boîte noire de l'appareil n'a
toujours pas été retrouvé l'avion l'un
des sept modèles exploités par air
france est en service depuis 1980 il
avait douze mille heures de vol au
compteur il venait tout juste d'être
révisé c'était le 21 juillet il y a
quatre jours
nous allons maintenant à gonesse sur les
lieux du drame retrouver claude son père
je rappelle que ce vol concorde d'air
france était un vol charter affrété
spécialement par des touristes allemands
leur claude quelle est la situation sur
place alors qu'il est écouté il ya
toujours sur place un énorme dispositif
de ce qu'on vous pouvez le découvrir
derrière moi nous nous trouvons
exactement à quelques centaines de
mètres de la zone du crash
près de 400 pompiers sont toujours la
fouille les décombres inlassablement à
la recherche peut-être de survivants
pour le moment le dernier bilan est
toujours le bilan que nous donne ici est
toujours de 130 personnes décédées les
100 passagers de l'avion les neuf
membres d'équipage effectivement quatre
personnes qui se trouvaient à proximité
de cet hôtel le relais bleu puisque le
concorde s'est écrasé près de cet avion
à l'entrée de la commune de gonesse pour
le moment il est très difficile ici de
vous confirmer une information qui
circule on parle d'un survivant mais je
ne peux pas à l'heure actuelle vous
confirmer cette information
je peux simplement vous rappeler que cet
avion décoller vers 16h40 et qu' il
s'est écrasé juste après son décollage
certains témoins que nous avons
rencontrés parlent ils ont vu ils
auraient vu un feu à l'arrière de
l'appareil cet appareil est
immédiatement tombé ici à quelques
centaines de mètres donc à l'heure
actuelle toujours 400 pompiers sur place
toujours des opérations de secours qui
se poursuit à la recherche éventuelle de
rescapés peu probable évidemment à la
recherche des boîtes noires de
l'appareil pour essayer de comprendre ce
qui s'est passé avec sans doute claude
le plan rouge qui déployait il y as 400
je crois 400 sapeurs-pompiers qui sont
sur place il ya un hôpital de campagne
tout près bien sûr vous le savez à
chaque grande catastrophe en france un
plan où j'ai même un plan blanc et
déclencher ce qui veut dire en clair la
mobilisation immédiate de tous les
secours ici ce sont les premiers qui
sont arrivées sur les pompiers de
l'aéroport de roissy mais vous avez des
pompiers qui sont venus de toutes les
communes de la région et y compris de
paris pour participer aux opérations de
secours ici parallèlement vous avez le
plan blanc qui a déclenché la
mobilisation immédiate de tous les
hôpitaux de la région y sont
immédiatement alerté les médecins les
équipes de chirurgie sont prêtes à
recevoir d'éventuels blessés pour les
traiter donc actuellement sur place vous
avez toujours c'est énorme dispositif
qui est là et qui travaillent
inlassablement
bien sûr il est le savez sur des
catastrophes aériennes il est très peu
probable de retrouver des survivants
mais on peut se rappeler comment sainte
odile en 1992
on avait retrouvé
neuf personnes rescapées donc ici les
secours n'abandonne pas il continue
inlassablement leurs recherches dans ces
décombres
merci claude et je vous confirme le
bilan provisoire enfin en principe au
fus officielle en tout cas pour
l'instant qui dont 213 morts avec
maintenant cinq blessés selon ce bilan
qui est donc provisoire une cellule de
crise a été mise en place
air france le numéro d'appel est le
suivant le 0 800 800 812 et puis un
autre numéro disponible à l'ambassade
d'allemagne au 01 53 83 45 00 01 53 4 83
45 00 par le 33 bien sûr si vous appelez
de l'étranger jacques chirac a aussitôt
exprimé son émotion le hasard a voulu
que son appareil au retour de tokyo
atterrissent juste avant que le concorde
ne s'envolent le chef de l'état a
téléphoné au chancelier gerhard schröder
qui se dit bouleversé par ce drame
de son côté lionel jospin s'est
immédiatement rendu sur place avec jean
claude gayssot
le ministre des transports je vous
propose d'écouter sa réaction un moteur
a pris feu au moment cet avion décollait
dieu de l'aéroport de roissy c'est un
avion charter qui avait été affrété par
un opérateur allemand et il semble bien
que toutes les pistes naturellement lui
était ouverte sur roissy et le bourget
que l'avion n'est pas pu revenir à son
point de départ même s'il a essayé mais
je peux pas vous en dire beaucoup plus
l' enquête va déterminer tout cela grand
moment d'émotion l'éprouver sur les
lieux du drame et assez effectivement à
un spectacle
ils vont saisir et donc je pense surtout
à tous ceux qui sont à la fois les
victimes de cet accident et tous ceux
qui dans leur famille aujourd'hui sous
voyons maintenant plus en détail quel
peut être le scénario cette catastrophe
certains témoignages très précis ont
raconté comment l'un des moteurs du
concorde a pris feu au moment du
décollage juillet debout l'aéroport de
roissy il est 16 heures 40
un concorde d'air france s'apprête à
décoller c'est le vol af 45 90 à
destination de new york selon des
témoins alors que l'avion prend de la
vitesse
l'un des quatre moteurs situés à
l'arrière gauche de l'appareil est déjà
en feu au bout de quelques secondes
une première explosion aussitôt après
c'est le crash à une dizaine de mètres
d'un hôtel de gonesse
c'est semble-t-il un problème de moteur
qui est à l'origine de l'accident
des moteurs olympus 593 construits par
rolls royce
ils équipent tous les concorde au sol le
bâtiment principal de l'hôtel n'est pas
touché l'avion s'est semble-t-il écrasé
sur une annexe
il n'en reste que des rues jacques
cardoze et l'ensemble de nos équipes sur
place ont pu recueillir les premiers
témoignages nous les écoutons
de l'accident une épaisse fumée noire se
dégage
l'appareil mythique d'air france vient
de s'écraser sur une partie d'un hôtel
au milieu des champs juste après son
décollage
il est 16 heures 45 plus d'une heure
après le crash des flammes continuent de
noircir la carlingue mais aussi l'hôtel
dans lequel se trouvaient plusieurs
personnes 4 y aurait été tué elles
s'ajoutent aux 109 victimes de
l'appareil deux témoins disent avoir
tenté de sauver ses passagers
prisonniers de ces flammes
il a vu des victimes à l'intérieur il y
avait des gens à l'intérieur des gens à
l'intérieur du siège mais tellement
épaisse et quand j'ai cassé la vitre
mais avec mon foot il ya les flammes et
la fumée qui est venu sur nous les armes
qui étaient autour ils ont pris peut
donc nous on a été en étant encerclé par
parler de la voir les flammes et la
presse qui retombe sur nous et nous
poule et donc on a été obligé de
ressortir après une fois qu'on a fait
les pompiers ils ont vu qu'il y avait
encore un bout de façade qui était
debout dont je joue aussi de rentrer à
l'intérieur
selon nos témoignages il semblerait que
l'un des réacteurs de l'appareil ait
pris feu
le concorde aurait ensuite tenté un demi
tour en vain j'ai vu l'avion avec le
flou
au fait c'est quoi le foot derrière est
en train de tomber sur youtube
ça s'est passé la montre est vrai que là
vous l'avez vu descendre ici
moi j'étais d'autres côté la vente
arrivé là où il ya la fumée l'appareil
était en pleine phase de décollage muni
d'une tonne de carburant comme à son
habitude il s'est écrasé après seulement
quatre minutes de vol il assurait la
liaison paris new york
une habitude pour air france mais cette
fois ci ce n'était pas un vol régulier
c'est un voyagiste qu'il a affrété peu
d'informations techniques nous ont été
fournis les un coordonnateur du trafic
aérien
présent au moment de l'accident a lui
aussi été surpris par la trajectoire de
l'appareil dans l'axé on voit donc les
bâtiments du fret et j'ai vu
progressivement l'avion donc d'abord
bâtonnière son axe mais ensuite
s'enfonçait en fait semblant il avait
pas de puissance il voulait garder un
axe et prendre de la vitesse
certainement les enquêteurs précisent
que l'avion se serait désintégré lors de
l'impact
un témoin nous dit que l'appareil aurait
pris feu dès son décollage l'a vu le
concorde passé avec des flammes sont le
moulage au décollage ont ils étaient
encore en train de rouler il est en
train de rouler pour décoller il était
déjà en flammes
ensuite caché par les bâtiments n'a pas
vu on est resté on a regardé on a vu un
peu plus haut en l'air en l'air il était
déjà avec des flammes aussi
il est monté droit un coup le commandant
devoir a essayé de repiquer sur la
gauche est arrivée à un moment là il est
resté il a plané comme ça il est tombé
d'un coup ce soir plus de 600 pompiers
sont encore présents sur les lieux
accompagnés de deux cents sauveteurs de
policiers de gendarmes des moyens
impressionnants ont été déployés pour ce
qui restera comme l'un des plus grands
drames de l'histoire de l'aviation
civile
nous trouvons donc maintenant au siège
d'air france jean bernard schmidt est ce
que la direction d'air france confirme
cette thèse donc d'un moteur qui aurait
pris feu quasiment au moment du thé
l'eau du décollage en berne à écouter
effectivement c'est ce que le pdg d'air
france jean cyril spinetta affirmé tout
à l'heure c'est à dire en plus
infirmant toutes les rumeurs vous savez
que l'on en a parlé ces derniers jours
de fissures micro fissures sur les ailes
du concorde ça il n'en est pas question
il s'agit bien selon la direction d'air
france d'un problème de moteur alors
immédiatement ici au siège d'air france
une cellule de crise s'est mise en place
dès l'annoncé de l'accident
elle réunit des spécialistes techniques
administratifs mais aussi la
communication ils doivent évaluer la
situation réunir les informations et
décider de la conduite à tenir lors
notamment vous lui donniez de thaler
décidé d'un numéro vert mais aussi faire
un gros gros effort de communication
interne à l'intérieur de l'entreprise
puisque de nombreux membres du personnel
d'air france appellent pour avoir des
informations je vous le rappelle même si
l'appareil était affrété
on l'a dit par un tour opérateur
allemand spécialiste des croisières de
luxe
les membres d'équipage eux étaient bien
des membres de la compagnie air france
et donc oui j'avais en arrivant il
semble bien que le le les vols suivants
de concorde dans les jours qui viennent
soit maintenant suspendue en attendant
d'en savoir plus sur les circonstances
de l'accident je ne sais pas si c'est ce
qu'ont confirmé hier france en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on reçoit ici de la part du
ministre des transports jean claude
gayssot
il faut savoir que brick et chaoui de
son côté a aussi décidé de suspendre au
moins les deux prochains vols
nous allons retourner maintenant à
gonesse près des lieux du drame où se
trouve claude son père claude
quelle est la situation maintenant
écouter les opérations de secours se
poursuivent ici nous sommes à quelques
centaines de mètres de la zone de crash
vous propose de découvrir des rémois
vous voyez il ya toujours sur place un
énorme dispositif de secours
plusieurs dizaines de camions de
pompiers des ambulances qui sont garés
les unes à côté des autres et je sais
pas si vous pouvez le voir légèrement
sur la gauche
sous cet os topo se trouve l'hôtel le
relais bleu et c'est prêt tout près de
cet hôtel que l'avion s'est écrasé vers
16h40 juste après son décollage
alors à l'heure actuelle donc les
opérations de secours se poursuivent
inlassablement vous savez qu'il ya
effectivement très peu de chance de
trouver des personnes rescapées
à cette heure-ci le dernier bilan est
toujours de 113 personnes décédées les
100 passagers de cet avion des allemands
qui partait destination new york
les neuf membres d'équipage et 4
personnes qui ont trouvé la mort à
proximité de cet hôtel lors du crash
donc les opérations de secours se
poursuivent peu de chance effectivement
de trouver des survivants on a parlé
tout à l'heure d'un survivant mais cette
information à l'heure actuelle de
londres où je me trouve sur à quelques
centaines de la zone du crash cette
information n'est pas confirmée le bilan
ici est toujours de 113 personnes
décédées les opérations de secours se
poursuivent et évidemment à côté des
secouristes se trouve à l'heure actuelle
des enquêteurs qui ont déjà commencé
leur travail
je cherche les boîtes noires de
l'appareil qui permettront peut-être
d'en savoir un peu plus
une enquête judiciaire évidemment a été
ouverte le bureau enquête accident qui a
l'habitude de gérer les catastrophes
aériennes prend les choses en main à
partir de maintenant c'est lui qui devra
dire et rendre très vite un premier
rapport qui devra dire ce qui s'est
passé tout à l'heure ici à quelques
centaines de mètres je vous rappelle
simplement qu'une enquête sur un
accident d'avion prend plusieurs années
on ne connaît pas à l'heure actuelle
toujours les causes du crash du mont
sainte-odile c'était en 1992 merci
claude et pour compléter ce que vous
dis-je voici ce que rolls-royce qui est
le dos donc le constructeur qui fournit
les moteurs du concorde a donc engagé
maintenant des investigations pour
essayer de savoir ce qui était advenu à
ce moteur qui semble avoir pris feu au
moment même du décollage le
c'était la première fois donc un
concorde s'écrasait depuis son premier
vol le 2 mars 1969 à l'époque l'appareil
constitue à lui seul un défi
technologique et c'est encore
aujourd'hui le seul avion civil
supersonique en service sur les lignes
commerciales hongrie concorde où l'avion
qui filent plus vite que la terre 190
tonnes de carcasses qui s'arrache du
tarmac en 30 secondes
une prouesse de la technologie le mythe
dure depuis 30 ans depuis ce premier vol
de 1969 le jour là pour la première fois
ton corps de ma volée c'est un dimanche
brumeux de mars
le concorde 001 effectué un vol d'essai
29 minutes dans le ciel de toulouse
vingt mille mètres d'altitude à mach 2
soit 2200 km heure le vol supersonique
sera l'avenir du transport aérien
c'est en tout cas le rêve que partage la
france et la grande-bretagne les deux
pays constructeurs du concorde
mais dix ans plus tard les chaînes de
construction s'arrête le concorde est
d'abord victime du choc pétrolier
puis de ses détracteurs américains qui
le trouvent trop bruyant les commandes
se font rares quatorze exemplaires ont
été construits
treize sont encore en exploitation
réservé à la jet set à tous ceux pour
lesquels volé dans le seul avion capable
de dépasser deux fois la vitesse du son
n'a pas de prix cinquante mille francs
c'est le billet aller-retour
paris/new-york champagne et caviar
compris un billet en or qui fait du
concorde un supersonique encore rentable
pour combien de temps jusqu'en 2010
selon air france qui ces derniers jours
n'envisageait pas de remiser le concorde
au hangar malgré l'apparition de
fissures sur les ailes de 11 appareils
un seul avion avait été immobilisé
british airways et air france estimant
que ces signes de vieillissement ne
mettait pas en jeu la sécurité des
passagers l'accident d'aujourd'hui
va-t-il précipité la fin du concorde
quoi qu'il en soit son successeur existe
déjà bel et bien en images de synthèse
comme un nouveau rêve qui ne parvient
pas à voir le jour faute d'argent
et je vous rappelle que ministre des
transports a donc décidé de suspendre
les prochains vols du concorde dans la
compagnie air france en attendant d'en
savoir plus sur les circonstances de ce
drame même chose chez british airways ou
par précaution on a aussi décidé
d'interrompre les vols de concours en
tout cas en ce qui concerne les pros
deux prochains vols je vous propose de
réécouter maintenant ce qu'a dit lionel
jospin tout à l'heure sur les
circonstances du drame ce drame qui a
fait 113 morts cinq blessés selon un
bilan qui est encore provisoire quand
cet avion concorde et france qui était
affrété par un voyagiste allemand s'est
écrasé écrasé près de gonesse à
l'ensemble des victimes à la fois
l'équipage à nos amis allemands aussi
qui sont pratiquement l'ensemble des
passagers qui sont concernés il ya eu
des personnes blessées dans un hôtel
dans une annexe d'un hôtel de ces
communes de gonesse qui a été touché je
pense que pour ces personnes la
situation est médicalement
bonne et j'ai naturellement au 6 juin
le chancelier schröder pour lui faire
part de notre de nos condoléances et lui
dire de transmettre
des victimes en allemagne nous pensé
voilà je vous rappelle que l'appareil
avait été donc affrété par une société
de voyages allemandes le groupe de 100
touristes tous donné suite allemande
devait d'abord se poser à new york pour
ensuite aller faire une croisière en
équateur ce soir la société peter delmas
ne fait aucun commentaire une cellule de
crise a été mise en place en allemagne
pour accueillir les familles des
victimes après donc cette catastrophe
qui a fait 113 morts sans passagers et
neuf membres d'équipage et 4 personnes
au sol
et puis cinq blessés qui se trouvaient
là aussi au sol puisque l'avion s'était
écrasé près d'un hôtel à gonesse
deviendront bien sûr sur cette
catastrophe à la fin de ce journal je
vous propose de déterminer maintenant le
reste de l'actualité avec d'abord
l'échec du sommet de cannes des vides
après quatorze jours de pourparlers
difficiles avec ou sans bill clinton le
sommet israélo palestiniens sous l'égide
des etats-unis s'est terminée sans
parvenir à un accord c'est ce que le
président américain lui-même a annoncé
au cours d'une conférence de presse les
commentaires de richard miné c'est un
bill clinton déçu et hésitant qui a dû
annoncer l'échec des pourparlers de
candé vide qui ont achoppé dit il sur la
question à jérusalem
ce fut le problème le plus difficile à
most et je dois vous dire que nous avons
essayé beaucoup d' approche différente
est ce que nous n'avons pas encore
trouvé de retour en arrière après des
mois de blocage du processus de paix le
chef de l'autorité palestinienne yasser
arafat poussé par sa base tente son
va-tout devant le conseil central de
l'olp et il déclare unilatéralement la
création d'un état palestinien
indépendant pour le 13 septembre 2001
signal fort à l'égard d'israël mais
aussi à bill clinton qui rêvent de
couronner son second mandat par un
succès diplomatique
les premières images de candé vides sont
idylliques les journalistes s'amusent
des politesses que ce fonds yasser
arafat ehud barak avant d'entrer dans le
chalet des négociations mais malgré les
déclarations rassurantes d'un bill
clinton souriant les rapports se tendent
les deux hommes en fait sont prisonniers
de leurs éléments les plus radicaux dans
les territoires autonomes
la colère gronde à hébron de jeunes
palestiniens tentent de déloger une
centaine de colons dans la vieille ville
tandis que des extrémistes israéliens
s'en prennent aux journalistes que 13
juillet yasser arafat s'irrite des
propositions américaines qu'il juge trop
favorable aux israéliens et menace de se
retirer des négociations
cinq jours plus tard c'est ehoud barak
qui veut quitter la table les valises de
la délégation israélienne sont prêtes
dans le hall de l'hôtel dans la salle de
conférence on attend la déclaration du
premier ministre israélien
tout semble finie mais bill clinton une
fois de plus parvient à réunir les deux
hommes les contacts se poursuivront sans
lui pendant son voyage au sommet du g8
au japon
à son retour hier il espérait encore
relancer la négociation
en vain enfin l'après midi les trois
hommes se séparait l'accord historique
n'a pas eu lieu alors charles enderlin
vous avez suivi ces quatorze jours de
tractations avec leur lot d'espoirs de
dramatisation de rumeurs d'échec ce soit
et consommer bien sûr c'est l'échec
personnel de bill clinton mais quelles
peuvent en être les conséquences pour la
paix au proche orient peuvent être
gravissimes de monsieur barak vient de
donner à quelques kilomètres d'ici une
conférence de presse il a lancé un
avertissement palestinien pour qu'il ne
procède à aucune violence au cours des
semaines à venir
sur le fond on ne voit pas très bien
comment le processus de paix pourra
redémarrer les positions sont trop
éloignées bill clinton dans une
allocution a semblé rejeter la
responsabilité de l'échec sur yasser
arafat kid at il dit a fait moins de
concessions qu ehud barak sur la
question de jérusalem
sur le fond donc monsieur barack revient
dans un israël où il n'a plus de
gouvernement pratiquement où il fera
face à des motions de censure de droite
bien sûr mais peut-être aussi de gauche
qui est très déçue de l'échec de ce
sommet
pour le proche-orient une nouvelle
période entre un diplomate américain
doit se rendre au cours des prochaines
semaines pour essayer de voir ce qu'il
peut être fait sur place mais cet échec
encore une fois peut avoir des
conséquences gravissimes envoyant quand
même que les négociateurs il paiera que
yasser arafat restait quand même à
cannes des vides alors qu'on avait cru
un moment que le sommet se termine et
qu'il restait bien que clinton sont
ailleurs au g8 et attendri attendait son
tour
on pensait quand même que les choses
allaient peut-être pouvoir se conclure
comment se fait-il que les choses aient
capoter de cette façon là parce que les
parts de ce sommet il y avait un grand
principe où il ya qu il ya accord sur
tout sur tous les dossiers
vous n'y a pas d'accord du tout cela
permettait à chacun de faire des
concessions dans la négociation et en
cas d'échec de dire nous n'avons rien
donné je n'ai rien offert aux
palestiniens je n'ai pas cédé sur
jérusalem c'est ce que ehud barak a dit
tout à l'heure à la télévision israël il
ya visiblement s'adressant à la droite
au bout au parti chasse aux partis
orthodoxes dont il espère le retour
pardon charles vous pensiez que l'ailé
août barack oui à ses rangs la fat avait
en fait intérêt à ce que ce sommet
n'aboutissent pas pour des situations
politiques intérieures je ne pense pas
je pense que tous les deux voulaient un
succès recherché le succès je pense que
les américains en mal calculé
l'importance de jérusalem-est pour les
palestiniens
nous savions aussi bien de sources
arabes que de sources palestiniennes que
la marge de manoeuvre de yasser arafat
était pratiquement inexistant je ne
pouvais pas être le premier dirigeant
arabe à céder sur jérusalem depuis en
fait depuis sa lada il y à des siècles
donc sur ce plan là je pense qu'il ya un
grand problème au niveau de la
diplomatie américaine
merci beaucoup charles je passais ce que
vous avez suivi donc toutes ces
négociations et puis que ma que vous
suivez cette affaire du proche orient
depuis maintenant des années que vous
êtes l'un des meilleurs spécialistes
voyons maintenant avec gérard griesbeck
et notre équipe sur place ce qu'ont été
les premières réactions en israël aussi
bien un côté israélien que côté
palestinien
c'était il y à une heure à peine le
premier ministre isralien expliquer la
raison de l'échec de camp david en
direct des états unis ou de barack
accusait yasser arafat de la
responsabilité de cet échec à jérusalem
chacun prend alors la mesure de
l'événement c'est vraiment dommage parce
qu'il faut faire la paix dans ce pays à
tout prix quitte à leur donner la moitié
de jérusalem savent où la vie d'un être
humain non
si bien qu'il n'y ait aucun accord nous
ne voulons pas leur donner jérusalem
soulagement de la part des colons
israéliens qui craignaient qu'un accord
ne soit conclu à camp david
depuis 14 jours ils campaient à deux pas
du bureau du premier ministre
certains d'entre eux faisait la grève de
la faim d'autres priaient pour que la
paix ne soit pas signé pour qu'aucune
concession ne soient consentis aux
palestiniens je suis très contente je
pense que c'était condamné à l'échec
depuis le début spécialement du point de
vue israélien du côté de la droite et je
remercie dieu que ça et échoué j'espère
que lorsque barack revient il y aura de
nouvelles élections dans la partie juive
de jérusalem les réactions sont plus
nuancés je pense qu'on a raté une
occasion de faire la paix mais je pense
qu'on ne serait de toute manière pas
arriver à un accord entre les deux
parties il faut être deux or nous
voulons la paix les policiers ne veulent
pas la paix ils veulent tous les
villages a failli le rifaa ils veulent
tout jérusalem
c'est pas possible
à gaza sous l'autorité palestinienne des
manifestations commencées dès l'annoncé
de l'échec de cordes avis les
manifestations de soutien y assez rare à
fouad de réjouissances car finalement le
leader palestinien n'a rien cédé
en france la vache folle et ce premier
cas détecté grâce aux nouveaux tests
pris aux knicks le test a été effectué
dans le cadre de la campagne de
dépistage lancé début juin par le
ministère de l'agriculture
et grâce à ce test les délais de
détection sont beaucoup plus rapides la
vache en cause faisait partie d'un petit
troupeau de la manche reportage de
cyrille devaud et de jérôme c'est qu'à
une petite commune de la manche chérencé
le roussel quatre vaches laitières ils
ont été abattus ce matin à l'abri des
regards
une cinquième vaches du troupeau était
contaminée par le prion
c'est le premier cas de vache folle
détecter avec le nouveau test de
dépistage appelé test rapide rapide car
il permet de tracter le prion à partir
d'un prélèvement cérébrale bovins en
moins de 24 heures
on utilise pour cela une réaction
chimique il fallait plusieurs jours avec
l'ancien test la cervelle découpés en
fines lamelles était longuement étudié
au microscope dans un seul laboratoire à
lyon désormais il y a trois autres
laboratoires à angers quimper est ici à
saint lô qui pratiquent le test rapide
grâce à leur nouvelle arme vétérinaire
et spécialistes s'attendent à découvrir
de plus en plus de cas de vache folle
si on prend la seule expérience d'à peu
près de la même grandeur qui a eu lieu
au monde c'est l'expérience suisse et
les suisses effectivement en appliquant
ce test ont doublé le nombre d'animaux
d'animaux positif qui joue retrouver est
ce que ça signifie qu'on a sous-estimé
jusqu'à présent le nombre de cas ça
signifie qu'en fait il ya un certain
nombre de cas qui était discret au
niveau pathologie et qui ont pu
effectivement passés au travers du
système mis en place
trente cas de vache folle détectées l'an
dernier déjà 29 pour le début de l'année
2000 avec le nouveau test ce chiffre
devrait exploser normale du gouvernement
plus on cherche plus on trouve c'est
parce que nous avons été chercher là la
maladie de sb grâce au test ce programme
très ambitieux que nous avons découvert
ce
peut-être nous n'aurions pas vu non
d'ailleurs c'est parce que nos contrôles
sont plus rigoureux qu'effectivement
nous avons plus de résultats une
campagne de dépistage systématique est
en cours 48 mille tests prévues sur tout
le territoire
les résultats attendus en septembre
donneront toute l'ampleur de la maladie
en france et nous allons maintenant
revenir avec peu de son père sur la
catastrophe de gonesse
vous savez un conte corps de carter qui
faisait la liaison paris new york s'est
écrasé près d'un hôtel à gonesse faisant
113 morts et cinq blessés au sol c'est à
peu près cela le bilan officiel plus de
100 perd à l'heure actuelle venoix le
bilan qui est donnée ici est toujours de
113 personnes décédées les 100 passagers
de l'avion
neuf membres d'équipage et 4 personnes
qui se trouvaient au sol mais je
voudrais tout de suite vous dire ce qui
se passe à l'heure actuelle ici vous
allez peut-être le découvrir dans
quelques instants
actuellement la police est en train
d'étendre le périmètre de sécurité car
selon la police des fumées toxiques se
dégagerait de la zone du crash d'eau
qu'actuellement les policiers vont fonds
dégagés la foule je sais pas si vous
pouvez voir les crs qui sont là à
l'heure actuelle ces policiers sont en
train de faire reculer les centaines de
badauds qui se trouvait ici à quelques
centaines de la zone du crash et ses
policiers sont en train de faire reculer
la presse la version que nous donne ici
c'est que des fumées toxiques se
dégagent de ces zones évidemment je peux
pas voulu confirmer tout ce que je peux
vous dire c'est qu'il ya toujours un
important dispositif de secours sur
place
près de 400 pompiers des dizaines de
membres du samu et un l'heure actuelle
donc la police est en train de faire
évacuer le périmètre
pour des questions de sécurité je peux
pas vous en dire plus merci le nourrit
donne quelques instants vont monter sur
ses terrains persique le dernier bilan
je vous le rappelle 113 personnes
décédées les 100 passagers de l'avion
neuf membres d'équipage et 4 personnes
qui se trouvaient au sol et pendant vous
parliez claude donc on a vu des images
de réaliser peu de temps après la
catastrophe
une enquête judiciaire a bien sûr été
ouverte on sait simplement par des
premiers témoignages que
un moteur de l'axé de l'appareil se
serait mis en feu juste après le
décollage ou concomitamment au décollage
nous allons trouver à bordeaux françois
grangier qui se trouve donc à bordeaux
et qui est expert judiciaire je crois
que sept pilotes instructeurs vous même
pas sûr qu'on cob en tout cas sur
d'autres appareils
quelle est la procédure après ce genre
de catastrophe mais écoutez la première
en d enquête va être l'enquêté
judiciaire diligentée par le magistrat
de permanence qui s'entourera
vraisemblablement d'un expert judiciaire
spécialisé dans les enquêtes
aéronautiques
lequel va travailler en bonne entente je
l'espère avec le bureau enquêtes
accidents chargée de l'enquêté
administrative dont le but va être de
déterminer le plus rapidement possible
des éléments de réponse à cet accident
de manière à pouvoir prendre des mesures
conservatoires peut-être l'arrêt
d'exploitation de concorde
peut-être justement la préservation de
cette exploitation et l'autorisation de
vol alors les éléments dont on dispose
ce sont bien sûr les témoignages et puis
aussi les fameuses boîtes noires la
plusieurs de quel type
alors il y a deux principaux
enregistreurs l'enregistreur de
conversations qui va enregistrer les 30
dernières minutes de conversations dans
le poste de pilotage ainsi que les
échanges avec radio avec la tour de
contrôle et il y a également
l'enregistreur de paramètres lequel lui
va délivrer les douze dernières heures
de fonctionnement de l'appareil
fonctionnement des systèmes des moteurs
vitesse altitude cap tous les éléments
pouvant déterminer la trajectoire de
l'appareil
alors vous êtes vous mêmes pilotes je
sais qu'il est très difficile de
d'émettre des hypothèses après une
catastrophe comme celle là mais enfin on
a quelques éléments avec ce que dit
officiellement air france qui parle de
problèmes moteur au décollage
qu'est ce qui peut se passer quand tu as
un moteur et pour quelles raisons un
moteur petit prendre feu au moment du
décollage
la panne d'un réacteur au décollage est
quelque chose de totalement connues
qui fait l'objet d'un entraînement
régulier pour les pilotes et que
l'équipage est à même de maîtriser sans
problème particulier
si cette panne survient avant une
vitesse critique que l'on appelle v1 le
pilote interrompra le décollage si elle
survient après il poursuivra le
décollage théoriquement toute sécurité
puisque les performances de l'appareil
au décollage sans calculer avec la panne
d'un réacteur cela dit concorde a une
particularité bien qu étant équipé de
quatre réacteurs
ceux ci sont jumelés deux par deux sous
chacune des deux ailes soit en panne
pour que l'autre réacteur 2 soit aussi
que l'avion soit déséquilibré cela 6 cl
si la panne est relativement simple
l'arrêt d'un réacteur
elle rentrera dans le cadre des
procédures connues
si la panne du réacteur et violence
destructrice
si le feu se propage sur le réacteur
jumeaux à ce moment là l'avion risque de
devoir faire face à la panne de deux
réacteurs
et ça c'est quelque chose qui ne peut
pas être géré dans la mesure où il faut
obligatoirement au moins trois des
réacteurs fonctionnant à plein régime
pour quoi permettre le décollage de
l'appareil l'avion monsieur grandgil
l'avion venait d'être révisées ça vous
surprend qu'un accident comme celui-là
puisse se produire juste après une
révision
la révision qui avait subi l'appareil
probablement une grande visite c'est à
dire une révision majeure sur l'appareil
consiste à vérifier des défauts
structurels des défauts de
vieillissement mais une panne peut
survenir même à l'issue d'une révision
surtout s'il s'agit d'une panne moteur
ou la défaillance d'un accessoire de
manière violente et évidemment sans
prévenir n'a strictement rien à voir
avec la vérification de l'état d'usure
en général de l'appareil de nos
questions j'imagine que dans une panne
comme celle là il n'y a pas grand chose
à faire pour un pilote le moment du
décollage et le moment le plus crucial
il ya environ 70 80 % des accidents qui
se produisent durant les phases
d'atterrissage et de décollage concorde
est un avion qui va très très vite
c'est un avion qui est peu performant à
basse vitesse et durant la phase de
décollage il est extrêmement vulnérable
si effectivement il à l'équipage a dû
faire face à la panne de deux moteurs au
décollage il n'y avait malheureusement
strictement rien à faire merci vous
prouveront en tout cas pour toutes ces
précisions françois grangier je rappelle
que vous êtes expert judiciaire est
pilote vous même à roissy se trouve jean
bernard schmid près du siège d'air
france jean bernard je sais pas si vous
avez entendu toutes ces précisions
données par monsieur grangier sur les
circonstances éventuelle de ce crash
il ya déjà des précisions techniques qui
sont apportées par la direction d'air
france en effet alors la première
précision technique est venue de jean
cyril spinetta le pdg de la compagnie à
savoir que c'est bien un incident de
réacteur et il a tenu lui même tout à
l'heure à évoquer la polémique qu'il
avait eu le sujet de microfissures sur
les ailes du concorde
je vous propose d'écouter jean siry ces
dates très très ému tout à l'heure je
souhaite dire puisque un débat légitime
elle lieu que parmi les avions encore
d'air france les six avions concorde
quatre d'entre eux avaient des criques
des fissures sur les rebords de voler
deux d'entre eux n'avaient pas celui ci
faisait partie du fait qu'il avait pas
de fissure
fissures étaient connus depuis février
2000 suivi de manière régulière tous les
cinq cycles pour que les deux
allers-retours en liaison très étroite
avec la direction générale de l'aviation
civile en france et avec la cia en
angleterre mais c'est avions là je le
répète faisait partie des deux avions
qu'il n'avait pas de fissures sur les
robots volée alors par mesure
conservatoire le ministre des transports
jean claude gayssot a demandé à air
france d'annuler ses prochains vols et
vols prévus pour demain sur les concorde
et je vous le rappelle la british
airways a également annulé ses deux vols
sur concorde prévue ce soir
à noter que plusieurs retards sur
d'autres vols sont remarqués ce soir à
l'aéroport de roissy à cause de cet
accident
merci jean bernard il faut rappeler donc
que c'était la première fois qu'un
concorde connaissait une un problème
majeur de cette de cette nature en vol
depuis son premier vol en 1969
je vous rappelle donc le bilan encore
provisoire qui donc de 113 morts et de
cinq blessés laissant personnes qui se
trouvaient à bord comme passagers parmi
lesquels se trouveraient en fait deux
danois un américain et une grande
majorité d'allemands mais nous en avons
nous n'en avons pas encore le nombre
les neuf membres d'équipage d'air france
et puis cinq personnes quatre personnes
pardon qui se trouvait au sol vous
propose de revoir tout de suite avec
arnaud beauté quels ont été les
circonstances de cet accident
16h44 soit deux minutes après son
décollage voici la zone où le concorde
af 45 d'air france s'est écrasé le lieu
s'appelle la patte d'oie un chant et au
centre un hôtel en se désintégrant au
sol
l'appareil a complètement détruit ce
bâtiment tuant quatre personnes qui se
trouvaient autour le concorde
transportés vers new york sans touristes
et neuf membres d'équipage tous sont
morts le bilan fait donc et acessoires
de 113 victimes
et on dénombre plusieurs blessés quant à
la cause de cet accident elle serait
selon air france d'origine mécanique
c'est ce que rapporte également certains
témoins au décollage au moment du
décollage j'ai vu le reiter côté gauche
qui est en feu
le second qui a pris feu et après quand
j'ai vu qu'on ne pouvait pas prendre de
hauteur et il a pivoté sur la gauche et
d'un seul coup il est tombé comme une
pierre
une enquête judiciaire a été ouverte sur
place près de 400 pompiers secouristes
venus de tout le département ont réussi
à maîtriser le feu
le plan rouge reste en vigueur et une
chapelle ardente a été dressée quelques
mètres plus loin dans un hôtel voisin
l'avion avait été révisée le 21 juillet
construit en 1981 il comptait douze
mille heures de vol il s'agit du premier
accident d'un avion concorde depuis 1969
date de sa mise en service des cellules
d'urgence ont été constitués des numéros
d'appel d'urgence existent aussi je
voulais redonner tout à l'heure et puis
une chapelle ardente comme nounou
l'isère le boutet a été installé à
gonesse près de l'hôpital
c'est là que nous retrouverons us mina
farber quatre heures après le crash la
carlingue est encore entouré de fumée du
concorde il ne reste plus rien sinon des
débris sur place la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de paris tous les
moyens du département restent mobilisés
un périmètre de sécurité est établi pour
garder les journalistes et les nombreux
badauds à distance
les témoins sont toujours sous le choc
ce qu'ils ont vu à quelques mètres de
leur voiture les a bouleversés
ils savent que le pire a été évité à la
saison du réacteur il a commencé à
descendre sur le
et ces spéciales très peu voire très bon
apport d'énergie
c'est pour moi il tombait à plat sur
gonesse comment j'ai pensé à ça je
dirais avoir démarré mais apparemment il
a dû tourner ou que sais pas qu'est ce
qu'il a fait mais en tout cas j'aimerais
scratch et ne vais pas tomber sur
gonesse
une femme femme elle avait les cheveux
brûlés le bois à brûler les partants en
courant ensuite elle pleure entrés dans
l'hôtel il ya des camionneurs qui
étaient là avec moi ils ont achoppé
les journalistes du monde entier
convergent vers les lieux du drame
l'image de cet avion supersonique
anéanti restera dans les annales des
catastrophes aériennes
signe qu'il ya peu de chances de
retrouver des survivants après les
ambulances ce sont les corbillards qui
viennent d'arriver sur le site
[Applaudissements]
voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire sur cette
catastrophe se crashe n'a un concorde
d'air france cet après midi en fin
d'après-midi vers 16h40 près du bonnet
ce à la suite semble-t-il d'un moteur
sur l'un de ses réacteurs l'avion un
avion de schachter un vol charter
affrété par une société allemande
c'est donc écrasé près de vénès avec 100
personnes à bord sans passagers et neuf
membres d'équipage et 4 personnes au sol
ont également été tués il ya aussi selon
un bilan provisoire
cinq blessés jour appelle des numéros de
téléphone que vous pouvez appeler si
vous pensez avoir de la famille à bord
de cet appareil pour air france et le 0
800 800 812 0 800 800 812 et puis pour
l'ambassade d'allemagne c'est le 01 53
83 45 00 01 53 83 45 00 bien sûr vous
faites le 33 1 si vous appelez de
l'allemagne ou d'un autre pays étranger
puisque je vous le rappelle la plupart
des victimes sont allemandes à
l'exception de deux danois d'un
américain et nous n'avons pas encore
tout le détail de ces touristes qui
partait donc faire une croisière sur
l'équateur vous propose de repos de
regarder maintenant un témoignage visuel
puisqu'il s'agit d'une vidéo amateur
réalisé juste après le crash
et nous venons de la recevoir
voilà c'est un document amateur qui a
donc été réalisé cet après midi et vous
le voyez alors que les pompiers avaient
déjà pu commencer à entrer en action il
y a eu 400 pompiers qui ont été
mobilisés pour cette catastrophe la plus
importante depuis longtemps dans
l'aviation civile en france la première
qui touche un concorde
le plan rouge a été développée a été
déployée le plan blanc également tous
ces plans qui sont donc destinées à
faire face à des catastrophes majeures
de ce type
vous voyez donc sur ces images assez
impressionnante réalisé par un vidéo
amateur reviendrons bien sûr sur cette
catastrophe dans l'édition de la nuit
avec aise mettez ce sera vers 00h50 tout
de suite vous avez donc rendez vous avec
nathalie rihouet pour la météo suivi du
film de claude sautet que france 2
diffuse ce soir en hommage à la mort du
réalisateur
il s'agit d'un coeur en hiver un film
avec emmanuelle béart et daniel auteuil
pour journal de 13 heures demain vous
retrouverez laurence ostolaza et antoine
cormery quant à moi j'aurais plaisir de
vous retrouver demain aux alentours de
20h bonne soirée sur france 2
[Musique]